Southwest Airline is under scrutiny for
its customer of size policy which allows
overweight passengers to request an
additional seat for free or book extra
seats in advance with a subsequent
refund this policy has drawn praise from
some Tik Tock influencers in the body
positivity Community critics CR critics
argue that this policy unfair to
passengers who can comfortably fit into
one seat and represents a compromise
driven by woke activism over customers
overall interest they suggest that
overweight passengers should be required
to purchase two seats if they cannot fit
into one rather than receiving an extra
SE this is not the first time obesity is
being worshipped and idolized in the
United States any other country would be
looked at gross because it is but it
just makes me regret ever dieting in my
life because if I was obese and hideous
I would have way more brand deals it
probably have a fat wallet right now I'd
get free seats apparently on Southwest